>> Will Sentance: Hãy nói về những lợi ích và
không lợi ích của cách tiếp cận này.
Vì vậy, 99% nhà phát triển không biết vấn đề này hoạt động như thế nào,
điều này làm cho việc gỡ lỗi chỉ là điều bí ẩn.
Và trên hết, tôi nghĩ là vâng, tôi đã nói rằng bây giờ,
trên hết, tôi cảm thấy phải đi phỏng vấn.
Mặt trái của phong cách này là nó tạo ra thứ gì đó có ý nghĩa
nếu bạn không hiểu nó hoạt động như thế nào, bạn có thể làm cho nó thành công.
Tôi sẽ nói về kiểu cũ mà bạn thực sự truyền một hàm vào,
nếu bạn hiểu cách nó hoạt động.
Bạn đã hoàn thành, phong cách này, bởi vì vẻ ngoài này,
phương pháp sau đó bạn nghĩ rằng bạn biết nó đang làm gì và nó hoạt động nhưng
thực sự, tôi ghét cái tên này.
Nó không làm gì cả, nếu tôi đang đọc mã này với tư cách là một nhà phát triển, tôi thích, được rồi, vì vậy
tìm nạp và sau đó tôi sẽ hiển thị.
Nhưng tất nhiên, nó thậm chí không gần,
có lẽ chúng ta thậm chí nghĩ như vậy nếu chúng ta quay lại chuỗi và thực hiện dòng đó và
rồi bit sau, Không, không, không, sau đó nên đổi tên là gì?
Tôi nghĩ rằng nó nên được đổi tên này, chức năng lưu trữ để Chạy sau, vâng, chính xác.
Dấu chấm ngày tháng trong tương lai, lưu trữ tôi để Chạy tôi sau tự động khi tác vụ nền
xuất phát từ cuộc gọi tìm nạp trước đó đã hoàn thành và
giá trị có thể được cập nhật.
Không hấp dẫn, nhưng nó chính xác, mm-hm, vì vậy tôi sẽ thêm một lợi ích nữa.
Vì vậy, mọi người nghĩ kiểu văn phong gọn gàng hơn, dễ đọc hơn,
Tôi sẽ nói, giống như đồng bộ giả,
Có vẻ như bạn đang chạy nó ngay lúc đó nhưng thực sự thì không.
Bạn đang chuyển một hàm sẽ được chạy như trước đây,
không phải bởi bạn, mà bởi JavaScript.
Và nó lấy một đầu vào mà bạn không đưa vào đó, JavaScript đưa vào đó.
Điều đó từ nền hoạt động rằng chuỗi cao sẽ tự động
được chèn vào chức năng hiển thị khi nó là AutoRun, tôi thích nó.
Nhân tiện, khi bạn thấy rằng JavaScript đã
người ta thấy rằng JavaScript đang sử dụng mã chức năng đó để hiển thị và
nó chạy nó cho bạn bằng cách tự động đặt Print trên nó cho bạn.
Và nó đang chèn đầu vào cho
bạn tự động Đó là một ngôn ngữ rất hào phóng theo nghĩa đó.
Có một lợi ích lớn của thiết kế này, và
đó là quy trình xử lý thời đại, vì vậy, điều này thực sự tốt.
Hóa ra mọi người, thực sự có một
mảng trên đối tượng hứa hẹn này đằng sau hậu trường, một thuộc tính ẩn khác.
Và nó được gọi là onRjection, và nó cũng là một mảng mà chúng ta có thể đặt các hàm vào đó.
Đặc biệt là khi bạn tương tác với thế giới bên ngoài
nội dung mạng bạn luôn gặp lỗi.
Bạn không muốn chạy các chức năng hiển thị của mình để người dùng trên Twitter có được một
phát toàn bộ chi tiết của lỗi.
Lý tưởng nhất là muốn có một chức năng riêng biệt sẽ chạy
xử lý lỗi đó.
Có thể nó ghi lại nó cho bạn theo một cách nào đó, nhưng
có lẽ chỉ mang lại cho người dùng trải nghiệm tốt hơn.
Nó đang làm điều gì đó tương tự, có thể, bất kể nó có thể là gì,
bây giờ, làm thế nào chúng ta có thể xử lý điều đó?
Chà, bạn biết không?
Đối tượng hứa hẹn cung cấp cho chúng ta tính năng tuyệt vời này,
điều đó có nghĩa là nếu chúng tôi nhận được lỗi không phải đối tượng phản hồi thực tế mà chúng tôi muốn có bất kỳ lỗi nào,
nó sẽ không chạy chức năng hiển thị đó.
Nó thậm chí sẽ không tự động kích hoạt bất kỳ chức năng nào của bạn khi chưa được thực hiện,
nó sẽ kích hoạt bất kỳ chức năng nào mà bạn đã lưu trữ trong onRejection,
làm thế nào để chúng tôi có được các chức năng trong đó?
Chà, có hai cách,
một người sẽ viết tương lai, >> Will Sentance: Data dot, có ai biết không?
Bắt dấu chấm chính xác, Cate đúng, bắt dấu chấm, và
bất kỳ chức năng nào chúng ta chuyển vào đó, nó sẽ bị từ chối, phải không?
Cách khác là tạm dừng để sau đó là đối số thứ hai,
bất kỳ chức năng nào bạn muốn sẽ vào đây để Tự động chạy khi bị lỗi,
đối số đầu tiên, gắn hàm đó ở trạng thái chưa thực hiện.
Sau đó, chúng ta sẽ lấy đối số thứ hai,
đầu vào thứ hai và giữ nguyên chức năng mà bạn đã từ chối?
Điều đó thực sự tốt, đó là một thực sự,
cách tiếp cận xử lý lỗi thực sự tốt mà không nghi ngờ gì.
Được rồi mọi người, vậy là đã có rồi, giờ chúng tôi có quy tắc cho
việc thực thi các chức năng trì hoãn mã trì hoãn không đồng bộ của chúng tôi.
Đây là những gì Dan đã nói chức năng trì hoãn hứa hẹn,
những cái được đính kèm với một lời hứa sẽ trì hoãn chúng chạy
cho đến khi một cái gì đó xảy ra trong nền.
Lưu trữ chúng trong hàng đợi microtask và các hàm gọi lại,
những cái đã được chuyển vào một trong những chức năng mặt tiền này như hẹn giờ, xin lỗi,
đặt thời gian chờ, để họ vào hàng đợi gọi lại.
Khi tính năng trình duyệt web khác có kết thúc API,
thêm chức năng đó vào ngăn mát.
Nói cách khác, Chạy nó khi ngăn mát trống và
tất cả mã toàn cầu đã chạy xong, hãy yêu cầu sự kiện kiểm tra lại điều kiện này cho chúng tôi.
Trước khi chúng ta tìm hiểu mã, tôi sẽ Chạy tiếp theo,
ưu tiên các chức năng trong hàng đợi vi nhiệm vụ hơn hàng đợi gọi lại.
Hứa hẹn về các tính năng của trình duyệt web, hàng đợi gọi lại và microtask và
vòng lặp sự kiện cho phép chúng tôi xây dựng các ứng dụng không chặn.
Chúng tôi không phải đợi trong chuỗi JavaScript duy nhất này,
chúng tôi không phải đợi ở đây để dữ liệu của chúng tôi quay trở lại.
Không phải chờ ở dòng này, tìm nạp sẽ không ở trên dòng này, đang đợi
dữ liệu quay lại, không, không, không, không.
Ý tôi là không trong mã thông thường,
chức năng của bạn tuyệt vời, bạn đang ở trên dòng đó cho đến khi bạn hoàn thành nó.
Nhưng nó không phải là một lệnh gọi hàm thông thường, nó là một hàm mặt tiền cho
thiết lập công việc nền.
Tuy nhiên, chúng tôi không thể đoán trước được khi nào các tính năng của trình duyệt hoạt động
sẽ kết thúc ở chế độ nền.
Chúng tôi không thể biết chính xác khi nào nó sẽ kết thúc, vì vậy chúng tôi không thể có dòng
mã sẽ sử dụng dữ liệu nền đó Chạy ngay bây giờ.
Chúng ta phải cho nó biết khi nào chạy,
chúng ta phải dựa vào JavaScript để biết khi nào công việc nền hoàn thành
để tự động kích hoạt, chức năng Chạy vào thời điểm đó.
Đây là những gì cho phép chúng tôi, mọi người, tạo ra những
ứng dụng năng động, nhanh chóng.
Chúng tôi có thể xử lý việc thiết lập rất nhiều thứ trong nền
trong khi chúng tôi chạy đua ở phía trước để chạy mã của mình,
đáp ứng các tương tác của người dùng, xây dựng các ứng dụng động này.
Đây là những gì thực sự làm cho JavaScript rất, rất đặc biệt và rất hữu ích.